these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific the place where myth and
science meet we use explosives to shake
the earth helping us to map the surface
of the island you're dropping bombs
scientific instruments
Oh
is it a monkey
like Efes n' you knew that thing was out
here I'm sorry for your man Colonel but
if you want to make their sacrifice
worthwhile
it is home with proof monsters exist
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comes
pretty good King keeps to himself mostly
well you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight
Cowen's god on the island but the
devil's live below us and what are they
called
I call them skull roars why never said
that name out loud before it sounds
stupid now that I say just you call him
whatever you want
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here ha ha he
should be coming here along to us
ancient species owned deserve long
before man